david meller
was a cabinet minister for in john
mage's conservative government in the
90s which itself became mired in
relentless sleaze scandals
he resigned as secretary of state for
what is now culture media and sport he
was famous he called the minister for
fun following a libel case and
revelations about a holiday in marbella
he joins us now
david meller you you invented if i may
start away from sleaze uh you invented
the role of secretary of state for
culture and you were the first minister
for fun
not much to laugh in about in yorkshire
right now what what do you think
we can do about what seems to be in a
completely shocking neglect
of racism in that club
well of course we don't know do we
exactly what went on it doesn't read
very well does it um that the next
captain uh says he was treated um
in a racist way and i think yorkshire
county club really needs to get open the
windows let the wind blow through and
get someone in who can actually
uh give an objective account of what
went on
do you think that there might at some
point be a role for government here if
the english um the ecb english
cricketing board doesn't uh
get a grip on it
well people are always saying there's a
role for government in sport it doesn't
usually work out that way and you've
just spent the last 10 or 15 minutes not
all together wrongly trashing what this
government does so the idea that the
government would bring any clarity to
bear on all of this is
is by no means established
well i i i think we just asked questions
here rather than trashing uh any party
or government but just the last video on
this um
is it your sense david miller that this
is just a yorkshire issue or would you
um you follow sport uh in various ways i
know
do you think this is a wider issue
well obviously it's a wider restriction
issue in society as a whole i think when
you look at britain compared i don't
know to a country like france we have
done a lot better in terms of um getting
people from a wide range of ethnic
backgrounds into senior positions in our
society we've only got to look at the
much maligned cabinet to see that
but equally plainly
those in charge of great institutions
and indeed you know yorkshire cricket
club in its way is a great institution
isn't it uh have got to ensure that
things complaints that are made are
properly investigated and they don't get
a chance to turn totally rancid as it
seems as what seems to have happened to
yorkshire i'm not a yorkshire man but
i'm sad to see
one of the proudest cricketing counties
in england produced so many great
players uh put into this
this this situation by inattention from
the top
all right well let's turn to the other
big story of the day and the reputation
of government um
you said that uh i spent the last 10 15
minutes on it uh what's your view
well i can understand why you spent the
last 10 or 15 minutes on it i mean i
think it's tragically this government is
a shambles and that's only on good days
um
i think it's astonishing that the prime
minister has allowed himself to get into
this model over owen patterson yeah owen
patterson was found by a committee which
consists of has already been said across
party membership consists of
independence
of what was called an egregious breach
of the rules he was paid a hundred
thousand a year by one company twelve
thousand a year by another company
and uh that um
was
a reason why of course he asks a lot of
questions but where i think it all went
hopelessly wrong is that patterson
instead of showing even an ounce of
contrition um then goes and says he do
it all
over again
given the opportunity and then we read
in the papers the following day the
boris is thinking of putting you in the
lords and i think you know the issue for
there's two issues for this government
that are related one is the prime
minister has many great strengths
but he doesn't seem to respect the rules
and he himself gets himself into trouble
with these rules and the fact that he
doesn't believe in rules will count
against him in in the long run the other
problem is this business with some
um with what ministers then do i mean i
couldn't believe it when um uh a cabinet
minister kwazii
went uh on the media and started calling
for catherine stone the regulators
um resignation what earth do you think
he was doing he was doing it because he
thought that would please boris
and a lot of them it's like a children's
party you know they want to please daddy
but the reality is a cabinet minister
should be above and beyond that i spent
nine years in
mrs thatcher's government and everyone
thought that she ruled everybody with a
rod of iron only partially true
throughout her administration
senior ministers stood up to her i
remember when ken clark was six state
for health i was his assistant as his
deputy we were doing a lot of stuff on
very important fundamental nhs reforms
he stood up against her
i i do want to come back to to the to
put this in historical context if i may
in a second but
what do you put down the fader this this
week too is it just the prime minister
not paying attention or the prime
minister's attitude or incompetence or
arrogance what what what is going on
here
i think it's an exciting melange of all
of them isn't it i i think jacob reese
mog who you know is sort of
his greatest creation is his own
personality but his own personality
greats a bit
he should have
come down off his rather lofty tower
that he inhabits and actually get into
the real world and see how this was
playing with the with with the public
um i think that the prime minister is
not bothered about the rules he doesn't
have ministers behind him with the
confidence to actually say prime
minister you've got this wrong so when
he decides
apparently after a dinner at the garrick
club would you believe he decides that
he will
whip the party to save owen patterson
he's allowed to do it the chief wit
doesn't stand up against him the leader
of the house doesn't stand up against
him none of his ministers stand up
against him because these ministers are
but they're really big people
but but but he
i think a lot of people in the party
would say mr miller he's a winner and
that's what politics is about and uh
contrast to i guess your day uh folks
don't seem to resign these days do they
or get sacked well he's a rock you know
old colleague of mine said boris is a
rock star it's got nothing to do with
boris's qualities which in other
respects are considerable he has an
ability to bond with people including
people from an entirely different class
and background himself well done him for
that but but where it all goes wrong for
him because when he abuses
that
power he has over people to do things
like he's done in the past week we
cannot have members of parliament taking
money
we can't
taking money in order to advocate cases
and while you may if i may say so i'm
quite sorry um in the years we've known
each other that you can only introduce
me in terms of of some supposed holiday
i just want you to know there was
nothing corrupt about that holiday tony
blair used to take holidays at other
people's expenses so do lots of mps
never a single complaint was made about
me to anybody so if you're trying to
equate me
with um owen patterson
it's i'm sad to see a man like you
playing that game okay it's it's that is
not really to do with the pattern in
fact i wanted to come precisely to that
point um the prime minister's holiday in
marbella
is actually about to be investigated and
i really wanted to ask you um that the
the rules have come in knowledge
principles and all of that
since you were a cabinet minister and
i'm really going to ask you whether you
think
you would have behaved any differently
had those rules been in place at your
time but i didn't behave in any way that
drew me i don't know why this is
suddenly turning and trying to meet 30
years ago
i did nothing above and beyond what was
the norm for members of parliament
because your introduction we've known
each other for many years and always got
on very well i can understand the only
basis in which you can introduce someone
who's done as much as i have done is
simply about some long forgotten holiday
with friends which of course that's what
members of parliament do all the time
well thank you david miller we lost him
on the phone well i simply going to say
thank you david miller for sharing
your the benefit of your extensive
experience rather than
any particular episode but anyway here
we are